let's say that you would like to build a
system to enable a robot like this to
pick up objects so this is what the
robot sees it sees images from its
camera and the goal is to Output uh
coordinates in space using some kind of
machine that you're going to build
that will allow it to pick up objects
successfully
now this is actually a pretty tricky
problem to solve because while you might
think that all you have to do is
localize where the objects are in the
picture and just output their position
in reality the right way to pick up an
object is actually actually has a lot of
special cases and exceptions that you
need to take into account so if you want
to really understand the problem and
design a solution manually maybe
rigid objects are you know fairly
straightforward to pick up you just put
the fingers on either side
but if the object is awkwardly shaped
and has a complex Mass distribution then
you need to really make sure you pick it
up close to the center of mass so it
doesn't fall out of the gripper and if
the object is solved in the formable
then an entirely different set of
strategies might be more appropriate
like pinching it
so anytime we have a situation that has
so many special cases exceptions and
little details it makes it very
appealing to use machine learning so
it'd be really nice to try to set this
up as a machine learning problem where
instead of having to manual engineer all
these little exceptions you could just
run uh some kind of a general purpose
machine learning procedure maybe with
convolutional neural networks to extract
suitable grasp locations from the image
automatically
the trouble is that the standard tools
that we have in supervised learning
don't make this very easy because they
require us to somehow obtain a data set
consisting of pairs of images and
suitable grasp locations but the problem
is that even people can't necessarily
determine grasp locations very well
because they're really a property of the
physical interaction between the robot
and its environment not necessarily
something that is very well informed by
human intuition to put it simply we
don't have a lot of experience picking
things up with robot fingers
so can we somehow use machine learning
but avoid the need to manually supervise
this process
well what if we actually get the robots
themselves to collect a lot of Trials to
attempt different grasps and see what
works and what doesn't work
that in essence is the main idea behind
reinforcement learning and the methods
that we'll discuss in this course will
in some ways address different uh
methods for tackling this type of
problem
so in a reinforcement learning setting
we wouldn't try to manually specify in
this case where the robot should grasp
objects instead the machines themselves
will collect the data set that doesn't
necessarily consist of good examples but
examples that are labeled with our
outcome so it'll be images what the
robot did and whether that led to a
failure or success more generally we
would refer this as a reward function
the robot would be rewarded for success
and not for failure
and then this will be used in
combination with a reinforcement
learning algorithm a reinforcement
learning algorithm is doing something
very different from a supervised
learning algorithm it's not just trying
to copy everything that's in the data
it's trying to use these success failure
labels these reward labels to figure out
what it should do in order to maximize
the number of successes or to maximize
the reward and then perhaps we could get
a policy that's actually better than the
average behavior that the robot carried
out while it's collecting data that
actually uses that experience to improve
upon what it would typically do
Okay so
that's kind of the bigger picture but
now let's let's put this in the context
of what has been happening lately in
artificial intelligence what are some
recent advances we've seen in AI well
the last few years have been very active
in artificial intelligence we've seen
pretty impressive advances for example
in the ability of AI systems to generate
pictures in response in response to a
textual prompt you can for example get a
diffusion model that where you can tell
it please provide a vibrant portrait
painting of Salvador to leave a half
robot face and will actually generate
plausibly looking pictures showing that
we could get language models that can
carry out conversations that can tell
you jokes about cows going to study
bowline Sciences at Harvard
you can get large language models that
act as assistants that can explain jokes
that can even answer complex coding
prompts
and even outside of the kind of uh
standard generative modeling
applications
we've seen a lot of interesting results
for example in biological sciences we
can get generative models that will
produce uh proteins that will bind to
certain kinds of viruses
so data driven AI has really Advanced
tremendously and we've seen a lot of
advances from image generation to text
to all sorts of other areas
a lot of these advances that have been
uh very much in the news in the last few
years are based on in some sense a very
similar idea to the supervised learning
approach uh that I presented as kind of
a straw man in my discussion of the
robotic example from before the
principle behind the image generation
models the language models in many of
these other settings is based on
essentially a kind of density estimation
estimating P of X or conditional that's
the estimation would be of Y given X so
per language models typically estimate
the distribution of natural language
sentences the image generation models
might be conditional Distributors over
images conditioned on that prompt but
it's a very similar kind of idea and in
both cases these are really just
massively scaled up versions of the kind
of density estimation that we learn
about in statistics class and of course
the a very important thing to remember
when you're doing density estimation
when you're doing a Centric supervised
learning is that what you're learning
about is the distribution in the data
and that makes it very important to
think about where the data actually
comes from
so if the data consists of
large amounts of images mined from the
web for example and those images are
labeled as textual problems then what
you're really learning about is the kind
of images that people put on the web the
kind of pictures for example they might
photograph in the case of text you're
learning about what people tend to type
on keyboards now these are very good
things to learn from if your goal is to
generate content that is similar to what
humans would have generated if your goal
is to generate the kinds of paintings
that humans would have drawn on the kind
of text that humans would have written
and that can give you a very powerful
capability but of course that's not the
only thing that we want from our
autonomous systems
so what does reinforced learning do
differently well before we talk about
that we need a little bit of kind of
historical background on what modern
reinforce learning is and where it came
from and really modern reinforcement
learning traces this lineage to two
previous disciplines the first one which
is the one that's actually called
reinforcement learning actually has its
roots in it's like in Psychology and
particular in the study of animal
behavior so this is a photograph Skinner
who is a very well-known uh researcher
who studied the behavior of animals in
response to various kinds of
reinforcement and much of the work
stemming from that line of research
forms the Bedrock of the kind of
reinforcement learning that we do today
in computer science Which models an
agent that's interacting with this
environment and adapting to its
environment in response to Rewards
but there's a different uh kind of
pedigree that also heavily influences
modern reinforcement learning which has
to do with controls optimization and
also has its roots and things like
evolutionary algorithms this is a video
from 1994 produced by Carl Sims that
shows an optimization procedure which
Tims did not call reinforcement learning
if you refer to it as Evolution but had
some more similar principles that was
used to optimize both the form and the
behavior of these virtual creatures so
these virtual creatures would do things
like locomote swim run around they would
even fight each other and their
behaviors would be optimized they would
be immersion so this is very different
from the kind of machine learning that
we think about today where the goal is
to reproduce the behavior of humans hear
the behavior the goal was to actually
produce behaviors that did not need to
be designed by humans
and if we fast forward uh a couple
decades we can see with more
sophisticated algorithms for in this
case automated optimization and control
this is a result by you will tell so
that shows a humanoid kind of simulated
robot automatically figure out how to do
things like Walk and Run and so on
so these two disciplines together
actually influence the study of modern
deep reinforcement learning which could
be thought of as the combination of
large-scale optimization with the kinds
of uh algorithmic ideas and Foundations
derived from classical reinforcement
learning and that's actually very
powerful because once we take those
classical reinforcement learning ideas
and we'll scale them up with the tools
of modern computation and optimization
then we can get very powerful emerging
behaviors
so many of you probably know about
alphago there was a very traumatic
moment in the alphago championship match
that was sometimes referred to as move
37 where the alphago system
performed a move that experts watching a
game are very surprised by
and
it was surprising because this is not
the kind of move that human players
would have likely made in these kind of
situations it was an emerging Behavior
now the generative AI results that we've
seen in recent years are very impressive
precisely because they look like
something that a person might produce
the pictures of pictures that a person
might draw the most impressive results
of reinforcement learning are actually
impressive precisely because no person
had thought of it what makes the results
in alphago so interesting to us is the
emergence the fact that an automated
algorithm could discover a solution that
goes beyond what people would do
and this is really really important if
we're going to take the study of AI
seriously because
we probably won't get the kinds of
flexible intelligence that we associate
with humans if we merely copy human
behavior we really have to figure out
how to get algorithms that discover
solutions that are the best solution to
the task rather than merely the solution
that a person would have taken because
then when placed in novel situations the
election respond intelligently
so this is the the motivational program
going to talk about
and in the remainder of this lecture
I'll take you through the structure of
the course and then describe a little
bit more some of the motivations for why
we should study deep reinforcement
learning today